The counters, we're going to go over some other genes that are in the gut section of your report.
Now, I understand I'm looking at the practitioner report, so your report doesn't have all the same
data on it as this one does, but the genes that we're looking at are on the first few pages of
your patient report on your genes. And there, this GRHPR gene, this family of three, and these ones that
are titled oxalate genes. Actually, these are all have to do with oxalates. Oxalates are important
for a few different things, and I'll be brief. The person that has a lot of defects in here,
and I would say this person that we're looking at does not have a lot of defects in here, but if you have
a two or two and some more ones that this person has, you have a considerable amount of oxalate gene
defects. Problem with that is this. Oxalates are a subgroup of compounds found in foods that aren't
bad because oxalates should never be absorbed when you eat foods that are good, greedily
if you vegetables have oxalates in them. So when you eat foods with oxalates, these genes right here
make an enzyme that break them down, and then you deposit them in the toilet. So they'd ever become
a problem. But people that have lots of twos and ones through these oxalate genes don't do that
very well. So then oxalates in their food become absorbed, and when you absorb oxalates, they circulate
through your blood, and then they try to exit through your kidneys. And that's what can cause kidney
stones. So high levels of oxalates in your urine, which you can measure on a urinary organic acid
test, which are some other labs that I like to do. Or just if we look at a genetic profile and people
have a lot of defects in these oxalate genes, a really good thing to keep in mind is number one,
you don't want to get dehydrated. So make sure you're stayed hydrated. And number two, it's super
easy to support this by taking a calcium supplement. So if I'm making a recommendation for a calcium
supplement, or you go, well, I don't eat that. I don't have bone problems. And maybe because
you have a bunch of oxalate defects here, or you have some urea acid cycle defects, your
uric acid cycle defects down at the bottom of this. We'll talk about that in another video. But you
can buy defects in your uric acid cycle with defects in your oxalate genes. You are a perfect
storm for kidney stones. And that can be a very, very painful thing to go through. And it's something
fairly easy to support. Stay hydrated. Number one, number two, take a calcium supplement that will
bind the oxalates in your gut and deposit them in the toilet. All right, hope that helps. Dakes.